NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Hey there, my name is Theo Steiner and you are listening to UIT Inside, our weekly podcast
for front-end developers who love user interfaces and technologies.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You might be wondering why I am speaking in English and not Japanese as usual.
The reason is, we have a special guest on the show today, and I am very excited for you to meet him today.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Eduardo, could you give us a brief self-introduction?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yes, sure.
Last week.
NOTE Speaker: posva
How was it?
It was great.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Honestly, it's such a nice conference.
NOTE Speaker: posva
To me, it's crazy.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
As someone who has organized conferences before, it's crazy how dedicated the team is, how
many they are, like 60.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think there were 60.
And the organization, the coordination, the level of detail is impressive.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I don't think we go that deep, at least in France.
You know, the conferences I helped.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So for some reason, I was like, oh, I'm going to do this.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
For people who are just doing that for free, I think it's really amazing.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's really impressive.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_2
I respect it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, it was also my first Vue Fest, and I was super blown away.
So like, I'm usually more active in the Svelte community, and we can only dream of having
NOTE Speaker: posva
a conference this big in Japan.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I mean, I'm trying my best, but so far, yeah, nowhere near that level of professionality.
And you actually, you did a talk at the Vue Fest Japan.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
We're going to dive into that later.
But first, how did you get to be a core contributor on Vue?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Like, what's your history in the Vue community?
So my history with Vue started, I think it's eight years now.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I didn't really know down the year.
Maybe I should at some point, actually look at the date.
NOTE Speaker: posva
But it's pretty early.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's pretty early days of Vue.
I started using Vue on version 0.12.
NOTE Speaker: posva
0.12?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, it was just released.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It was right after 0.11.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
For example, I know Kazupon, who is also a core team member.
NOTE Speaker: posva
He's a member of the team.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And was one of the organizers of Vue Fest.
He was there in 0.11, maybe before even.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so I remember seeing his face already in the issues and pull request.
And so initially, I was working at a company as a consultant.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I was really young.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I was right after my studies.
And we were doing a lot of AngularJS.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I don't know which version it was at the time.
I find as I kept using it, I found a lot of issues.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And also the mental model didn't fit the way I like to think.
So I felt like it was getting more in the way.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I would check up documentation more often than not.
And in the evenings, I would check out all the libraries that were existing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think Riot was also one of the libraries at the time.
React, of course, was also there.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And Vue really clicked with me when I started using the documentation.
I started building projects because of the simplicity.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it was a very different time, honestly.
The whole bundler scene was not there.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
We were still using Gulp and Grunt.
So it was very different.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The kind of performance, not performance, but things were not as fast when building,
NOTE Speaker: posva
right?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So we have other interests in other things.
And it was more in the API and how simple it made to communicate between I have this
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
mental model of data I want to display and I want to base that as a source of truth.
And I want it to render always and to always be updated.
NOTE Speaker: posva
That was the main, main issue, the most important one.
I think nowadays we forget about that a lot.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think it was a lot, but in those days it was very important.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I started using it a lot.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I started diving a lot in the issues, commenting here and there, sometimes helping out with
triaging mostly, I think.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I would help people, help people with their issues to see if there were bugs or not.
So I will tell them, oh, you're just doing this, but you should be doing that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
When I look back, back at my comments, I can see that there is a lot of, at least I improved
NOTE Speaker: posva
a lot.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It wasn't that great back then helping people.
Also English is obviously not my first language.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Although I'm fluent, I think a few years ago, I would definitely have a different
NOTE Speaker: posva
tone with speaking.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So maybe more direct, or I would just not have the same level of subtlety when speaking,
which is fine in open source, I think.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So at some point Evan also asked for a core team to be formed and to reach out to him
via form maybe, I think, in order to more formally, more formally, more formality, more
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
of a formality to create a team, have a Slack, and we could discuss about things a little
bit more organized.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so that's how I really got into the Vue core team.
I think, so Kazubong was also there, and we were like 20, a bit less.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
A lot of the people from the initial team has disappeared, not disappeared, but they
NOTE Speaker: posva
are not there anymore.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Maybe they passed on to something else.
In the end, it's always difficult, I think, to contribute to open source and have a full
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
time job.
Definitely something you cannot do at all ages.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think the window is actually very short.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_3
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Or you have...
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You have a life where you have a lot of freedom, which is not something everybody can afford.
And as again, with age comes more issues, even with health or anything, you have more,
NOTE Speaker: posva
you're more likely to have issues.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
If you want to have a family, then that's another thing.
NOTE Speaker: posva
You have more responsibility.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So yeah, there is a small window, I think, in developer's life where you have these opportunities
to join some kind of community and try to be part of it in different ways.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And once that time window has passed, you can not join in the same way.
Or because you cannot, you won't be able to find yourself.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So if you get the opportunity, you have to grab it.
I'm already wanting to go off script because you said you started with Vue version zero
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
and I only started with version three.
So I'm really interested in what the API looked like at version zero.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It was honestly the biggest difference is options API.
At the beginning, it was really based on options.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So we have separations of type of things.
NOTE Speaker: posva
We have data methods.
We have a lot of things.
NOTE Speaker: posva
We have computed.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
There was a compiler.
Where is it?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think there was no compiler in the beginning.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Compiler is V1 or V2.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Maybe V2 actually.
So it was more of modifications to have done directly.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But I think Angular would also like that.
And the main idea was there and it hasn't changed.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The fundamental idea of having a source of truth and you write your template and you
have some syntax on top of HTML that is still valid in HTML was there.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Also, you had a lot of and this was a big strength back then.
It's not a big strength that more than much anymore, but it's still something that only
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Vue has compared to any other framework in front end.
It's that you can still have an HTML.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You have your page with HTML and you have these extra things that are Vue.js specific
and you add JS on top for the Vue and it will re like not hydrate because it's not SSR.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's not the right term, but it will rebuild the HTML.
So it's not a big deal.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you don't need a build phase.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Essentially, that's the point.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You don't need a build phase to actually use Vue.
And some projects I did in a consultancy, which now use Nuxt, if I'm not mistaken, but
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I haven't been there for many years.
They started using Vue 1 and Vue 1 with templates and in the back end, it was like symphony.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So PHP and Vue helped us have a more maintainable front end code than using jQuery.
So it really it really was a better replacement for jQuery.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It helped to have this concept of components also, which hasn't changed.
NOTE Speaker: posva
The concept of components has been the same.
So yeah, that was the big thing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
No build phase and only options API.
Yeah, everything has changed a lot with composition API, but you can still write option API today
NOTE Speaker: posva
and it still works, which is yeah, the backwards compatibility of Vue is great, I think.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you're a very proficient open source library author.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And as you said earlier, maybe best known for Pinia and Vue.js.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I'm a router or router, however you say it.
NOTE Speaker: posva
American.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So let's dive maybe a bit into Pinia.
So Pinia is a state management library.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
We use it actually here at Line Yahoo Corporation.
And thank you for that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So what does Pinia enable?
So Pinia, it doesn't enable that much.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And that's the good thing about Pinia.
And it really is about global state management and having a centralized solution that is
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
safe and is compatible to use.
So it's the official state management solution.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You don't need to use it in other projects.
And you could get away by having like global, even global refs in some projects.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's more about the some standards it introduces.
So people when going from a project to another, they will still be able to use the Pinia functions.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The API honestly is very small.
In the end, the surface API is really small.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The idea really is to be able to define global state in a way that looks like Vue.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So Pinia is very, very simple.
It's a very simple, very easy to use.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And it's very, very easy to use.
So for example, you have two types of store.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You have option stores, which are going to look more like options API.
So you also have state, you have getters and actions, which basically is the equivalent
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
of a component data computed and methods.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's pretty much the same.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you can also see the store as a component without a template that is always there, that
is outside of the tree of components.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And then you have setup stores, which are like composition, so composables, which are
functions that use the composition API.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So you can see the store as a component.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You have the function API to encapsulate logic.
And so these offers a very low level of granularity.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You can really split up things, organize the code, the data, the functions the way you
NOTE Speaker: posva
want.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so Pinia allows to define a global composable, kind of like a singleton.
And it works with SSR, it has dev tools as well.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it really tries to make things as close as Vue for state management.
And it was also a way to migrate more easily from Vuex.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Because Vuex is not only a state management tool, but it's also a way to migrate more easily from Vuex because Vuex is a state management tool.
And so Pinia is a very good example of this.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's at the time of Vue 3, even Vue 2 has a poor TypeScript support.
And this is also inherent to the way the API is created and the way you interact with the
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_4
store.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
We would have what we call magic strings.
So we would access the store via these in components, dot dollar store, for example.
NOTE Speaker: posva
We have dollar something.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so there is no way to infer, I mean, you can infer with some manual code now in TypeScript,
NOTE Speaker: posva
but not any of the time.
It wasn't that easy in the time.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And it has other issues like you always have a big store with everything inside, even if
you create modules or you have to do dynamic modules.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But it's still it requires some extra code.
So Pinia has been engineered in a way that it doesn't get in your way.
NOTE Speaker: posva
All these things, you get them for free is inherent to the API.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I think I'm really happy with that part of things that it's mostly people don't don't
really see them because you don't need to.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And I think that's the best kind of API when it's invisible.
Yeah, that's true.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's a very lightweight API.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_5
And I love your work.
I love your work.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I love your explanation of it basically being a component that is shared between other components,
but it doesn't have a template.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And that's like, especially true since you can use the composition API and the option
NOTE Speaker: posva
API.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it's, it's almost like a view component without a template.
Yeah, as I said, so a question regarding the the way you author Pinia stores is the composition
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
API is it like recommended to use it over the options API?
There is no like recommended.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because it depends what you mean by recommended, right?
For me personally, yeah, I prefer to just you always use composition API, just to have
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
a more coherent writing of stores.
The reason is, there are things you cannot do with options, option stores simply, because
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
you are limited to are organizing things by type.
If you want to go have, what is the word in English, if you want to live it up your your
NOTE Speaker: posva
your game and the way you organize code, you will have to go to a lower level.
So you can't do that.
NOTE Speaker: posva
You can't do that.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_6
NOTE Speaker: posva
You can't do that.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_7
NOTE Speaker: posva
You can't do that.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_7
NOTE Speaker: posva
So you have to go into a lower level in terms, sorry, you will have to go into a lower level
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
of code organization, which means that you are exposed to more risk, but you also have
NOTE Speaker: posva
more control.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And this is where you should learn and grow.
And this is where you can create actually better code organic organization than just
NOTE Speaker: posva
having a type organization.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So because of this, personally, I will recommend to use the setup stores whenever possible.
But some people are still not there, they are learning, and the option stores are there
NOTE Speaker: posva
for them too.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think this is also a good point to show that for people starting view was also a great
choice because of this because of the options API.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So when people are starting, they feel so much more comfortable not having to think
about where to put things.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because the they are organizing by type is like having a I forgot the word where you
put your socket like a structure, not a structure, but in your clothes closet, where you put
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
your your clothes, you usually like a drawer.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Exactly.
Thank you.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you can organize each kind of things, right?
Most people organize them by kind of thing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I have t shirts, you have pants, you have socket socks, you have underwear, right?
NOTE Speaker: posva
So this is very easy to do.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think mentally, we are used to this kind of mental model.
That's why it's also very easy for people to get started with view and why it was so
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
attractive for people in the first place, especially in view v1 and stuff, because people
just will look at a view code and be like, Oh, I understand right this right away, because
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
they can see data, they can see methods.
Now, when it gets complicated, the component is not easy, right?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So that's why the composition API helps.
Very interesting view as a drawer for your mind, or like the options API as a drawer
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
for to organize your code.
Okay, so that's Pinia.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And you're also known for another very, very big library, you've router, how did you come
NOTE Speaker: posva
to write view router?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I think it's like the most common router API and not router, the most common router library
NOTE Speaker: posva
in view.
So how did it come to that?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So in view, we have official solutions.
So the idea is we gather feedback, we consider also a lot of backward compatibility things.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And we try to move fast when we need to move fast, and then we move slow to not break things.
So I think I applied this well to your router, because I slowed down on the parts where I
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
could break API's.
And I went fast when I needed to, but I still took the time it needed to develop.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I got into it very early on my journey with view, I think.
And I wrote the v4 version.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So there was a lot of things to take into account.
The v4 version of your router is for view three.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And routers are very interesting topic.
Everybody takes them for granted, but they're very complex.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And their responsibility spans all over the application code.
So it's it's a really hard piece of software to design property.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And sometimes it's better not to over design it.
So by that, I mean, not creating too many API's.
NOTE Speaker: posva
But rather exposing lower level API's.
So that's the first thing.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And then the second thing is, I think, is the user experience.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because people have opinions, and people want to use their own abstractions for some stuff.
So it's better to not over commit in an API that might end up not being useful in many
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
cases, but still adding to the bundle.
And ViewRouter is one of the most powerful routers out there, actually, when you in terms
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
of features, it has been way more powerful than any other in many years.
Now we have a lot of typed routes and typing like parameters.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And there are a few features now that I'm still adding back to the router.
But even though it was one of the pioneers, I think, in typed route in typed pages and
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
type safety in ViewRouter, we have these for two years now.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And there are other concepts that were not there.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So for me, it was a very interesting topic, but very time demanding.
And it's a big challenge because people don't really take a look too much into the router
NOTE Speaker: posva
or it's like, yeah, it's just there.
Also maybe a marketing issue on my side, to be honest.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I recently dove into your ViewUnplugin router, the one that has like full type safety and
NOTE Speaker: posva
file based routing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I have to say that it's like a new way of doing routing because it's like end to
NOTE Speaker: posva
end type safe.
And I don't think we had that before in the view world.
NOTE Speaker: posva
No, no.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I mean, oh, actually, yes, we did have some things that were so there was something in
the Nuxt ecosystem that was similar.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I think I talked to the author of the library.
NOTE Speaker: posva
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I'm not completely sure.
I'm trying to roll back to rewind in my memory.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So they had something similar.
They were using a different approach because they were only for Nuxt, right?
NOTE Speaker: posva
It was specifically for Nuxt.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you already had the file based routing.
It's a little bit different, but the idea is still the same.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Based on the file structure, you can infer the types of the routes.
And the way you do it in ViewUnplugin router is really cool with the like you create virtual
NOTE Speaker: posva
modules.
Yes, yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And then you import types from the virtual modules.
That's like as a as a techie.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I just like that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
When I saw that, I was like, Oh, this is so cool.
It was a big headache with the with TypeScript.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Sometimes he's I can imagine he doesn't work and you don't know where to debug because
it's mostly the augmentation.
NOTE Speaker: posva
You have to solve the type.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, you have to you remove stuff.
You comment stuff out and you're like, Oh, now it works.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I comment this out.
Now it doesn't work.
NOTE Speaker: posva
You start tweaking things.
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Type augmentation is can be a pain.
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's a pain to debug for sure.
So the ViewUnplugin router brings us to the next section of our episode.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You actually had a talk at the ViewFest Japan, an amazing talk.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I really enjoyed it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And it was titled Async State Management with ViewRouter.
So what what is up with that?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
What is async state management with view?
State management is so when something funny is people usually when they hear async state
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
management, they hear async and then state management.
But the real split is async state management.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And it's just a differentiation from state management or global state management.
When we say state management, it can be both.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Async state management, it's just a very generic word to say we handle the async state.
So that means is the operation running?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Do we have an error?
Do we have the data back?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Can we refresh it?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So there is a lot of things around that and we can add things like cache, persistence,
NOTE Speaker: posva
refreshing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So by not refreshing, but rehydrating from the persistence, pausing, resuming.
There is a lot of things you can go really, really far.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So most of the time, this means data fetching in web applications.
We're not going to lie to ourselves.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The truth is that it still goes a little bit further.
The truth is that it still goes a little bit further because you can also integrate other
NOTE Speaker: posva
kinds of async state management.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you could have WebSockets and other more complex operations.
But data fetching is going to be the main topic.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I'm going to limit to talking to data fetching.
Because it should be what most people are familiar with.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It means that so the talk was really about combining these data fetching that is not
always in the router to the router and the benefits of doing so.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The most of the time when you do data fetching or async state management in general, you
have some kind of solution that handles that.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Is it loading?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Did we have an error?
Otherwise if you write the code by yourself, which you can, it's a lot of boilerplate.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you end up abstracting it and then you keep adding features.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And then it becomes a bit of a mess.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And you may end up writing your own library like like that's the query swear or not have
NOTE Speaker: posva
their own implementation.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So the talk is more about is really about combining these solutions with the router
to bring also the benefits of being able to integrate data fetching into the navigation.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because well, there is a lot of some of the benefits that are talked about in the in the
NOTE Speaker: posva
talk.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But there can be easily summarizing to you want to be able to control the navigation.
NOTE Speaker: posva
This means redirecting to a page.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
If the user has no access, display the page with an error, maybe if it's a 404, when you
want to display the detail of a of a document in the database, but also having a better
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
analysis knowledge of what is going on in your page.
So if you just load the data synchronously on when the component mounts, your navigations
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
are going to be instant, and you will not have any metrics on what are the pages that
take the longer to load from our client side perspective.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Because if you have service and rendering.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
As long as you load the data on the server, you can see how that so it's more of a realistic
point of view on what is fast, what isn't fast in your application, integrating into
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
the navigation allows you to know how long take on the client side some of the pages.
So analytics wise, this is very nice too.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And so this is that's it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
That's the that's the point, right is having these benefits, but without giving up all
the benefits of using a full fledged as in state management library, and this is the
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_8
data loader, basically, or loader.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The name is not really sexy, but I don't think it requires to be that.
It's just it's loads something.
NOTE Speaker: posva
That's it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So my understanding is that data loaders are implemented on top of route guards or route
guards like the before enter route.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_8
Yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, route guards or middlewares, you can call them whatever you want.
The concept is the same is a function that runs before the navigation is confirmed, and
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
allows to control the navigation outcome.
By control, I mean cancel.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So abort redirect.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And also delay.
It's a synchronous.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, I think that really gives you a lot of flexibility because you can get the data
and look into the data and decide based on the data you got where you redirect the user
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
to or if you have to cancel or do something else.
It's a really beautiful pattern, I think.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Did you have like, any any sort of inspiration for this pattern?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah, definitely.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I try to when I come with these ideas, I mean, the loading into a navigation guard,
that's something that has been has existed for a long time.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But I wanted to have an API that allow me to collocate the code that is relevant to
data fetching to the code that displays that results.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So usually this means page components.
In page components, I want to be able to define loaders without being limited to it.
NOTE Speaker: posva
This is also the important part.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I don't want to be limited by this collocation.
And I want to be able to use it right away underneath.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
When you have the navigation guards, you really are away from the component because it's a
NOTE Speaker: posva
global thing.
It's in the router.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I did look at what the navigation guards are.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I did look at what other frameworks were doing with loaders in general, because every single
framework had their own version of loader.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And they are mostly doing a very simple version compared to the version I'm doing.
So I wasn't really satisfied with the inspiration I got.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But it was still great to see that other people were going in a similar direction, because
I've been trying to advocate for the navigation in navigation data fetching for a long while.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And some of them do not really integrate into the navigation because they only do it on
server side, but not on client side.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And so data loaders are basically the same.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
They're both server and client side.
They're really hooked into the navigation itself.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so the reason I say that some of the frameworks have a more simplified version is because
they don't allow, sometimes they don't allow multiple loaders, for example.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
They don't allow nesting loaders, which is something I didn't talk about in the talk.
But you can nest loaders and have serial, by default is parallel, which I didn't even
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
say, but because I think it should be granted, like take it for granted.
Your navigation should maximize the parallelization of loading.
NOTE Speaker: posva
As well.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you can do the best, as much as it could.
And so the data loaders do this and you don't even need to worry about it, but you don't
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
need to have one loader per route.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_4
You can have multiple ones.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you don't even think you need that and you don't even need to think about it.
And then you can also combine it with the full fledged libraries that bring all the
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
features like cache, persistence, as I was saying before, or just do the basic one.
So that's definitely something that no other framework has, right?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Having a loader that can be augmented like a spec.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's maybe a level lower than other frameworks.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_9
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
If I, for example, think of Remix or SvelteKit, which have a similar loading pattern, but
then it's not as composable because you don't have the loader itself that you can freely
NOTE Speaker: posva
pass around.
Exactly.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You can still, for example, in Svelte, you could use the loader that is in your layout
and await it or something, but it's not as composable and low level as the data loaders
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
in Vue Router, which I think are really nice.
They're really cool, but they don't have this general, like a standard pattern.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And what I especially love about them is that there is not one data loader.
Like in your talk you were like, actually I lied to you.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
There's no data loaders because data loaders are just a spec.
And for example, one that comes default with Vue Router is the basic.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Yeah, you have two defaults.
So like two official implementations in a way is the basic, as you were saying.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So you can rename it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
bother too much with the naming is like define define basic loader and this is just takes a
function that returns a promise that's it and then the sorry and the colada there is the define colada
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
loader so this one is based on pinia colada and pinia colada is is a layer on top of pinia so you
can call it whatever you want is it uses pinia to so more specifically the stores to handle the
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
the data the global data the global state management and it adds sprinkles on top the
all the goodies for cache sync state and invalidation optimistic updates a lot of things
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
that are really useful and it makes it also in a way that is really progressive which is something
we really like in Vue so it should be simple to get started it should be simple to go further
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
away by adding things so you shouldn't be rewriting your whole code when you need to
NOTE Speaker: posva
make things more complex
you shouldn't be rewriting your whole code when you need to make things more complex
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
most of the time you should be able to just add things to the to the code you already have
and still stay simple i want to dive into pinia colada a bit further later on but like other than
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
the two basic loaders um you provide by default what what kind of loaders could be implemented
what like why is it a spec yeah it's a spec because i didn't want to lock in my users into
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
some specific implementation so the basic loader doesn't use any other library right it doesn't
have any other implementation so it only has data error loading state and you can refresh the data
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
without navigating that's pretty much pretty much it error management loading state data and
refreshing and any any implementation can add their set of features so like pinia colada does add the
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
cache and persistent annotation invalidations this is handled by an external library which is
independent to the router it works by itself right so we have some glue code you can you can even
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
think about the define uh the loaders as a whole but i'm not sure if we can get a lot of validation
loaders as glue code.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And then you could have something with other libraries
that other people use.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So it could be TanStackQuery, which
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
is a very popular solution for async state management.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And Pina Colada actually has an API
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
that looks a lot like TanStackQuery.
It's obviously on purpose to be able to seem familiar to people.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And you can also do ViewFire.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So ViewFire would have the, what would be special about ViewFire
is that you will wait for the initial data to be ready,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
and then it will become real time, something like that.
And so WebSockets, you could imagine something similar.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You wait for the WebSocket to be set up and the connection
to be ready, and then it's just alive.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's just there.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Of course, you still need to handle
some of the intrinsic behaviors of WebSockets,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
like disconnecting and stuff like that.
That's a whole different story.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you could imagine any loader that
integrates with any other technology, library
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
or technology, and that brings their own very special set
of features that is not specific to data loaders.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because the idea is really, as long
as you implement these internal, like,
NOTE Speaker: posva
I mean, low level API that the router relies on
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
for the navigation guard to run and to get data, it will work.
And it has a lot of features that are actually
NOTE Speaker: posva
more complex to implement that it looks like,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
like the ability to have consistent updates.
So the loaders are meant to delay updating the data
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
until navigation is validated, which is very abstract concept.
But when you have client side loading based on the routes,
NOTE Speaker: posva
if you navigate to a different route,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
and you have multiple parts of the application that
NOTE Speaker: posva
have different fetches, you may end up
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
with data that arrives at different times.
And so, for example, you have profile information,
NOTE Speaker: posva
which is the demo that I showed.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You might have some information that takes longer to load.
And you will have the information of the user
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
be displayed with different user information, actually.
But it looks like you're looking at one person.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you have, like, this Frankenstein of information.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So data loaders also are meant to fix that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And no matter what library you use,
of course, you need to implement it
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
and I have a big suit of tests that you need to pass in order
to say, OK, this is a compatible data loader, but it's there.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's .
That's really cool that you're trying
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
to verify that the community provides are actually
functional data loaders.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So given you can use Pina Colada or something like Vue
Query inside the data loaders, I wonder how they make data
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
loading, I think declarative is the key word here,
NOTE Speaker: posva
where you define the dependencies.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you can use the same thing for a set of data
and you refetch the data whenever the dependencies change.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
How does it work if I put the declaration inside the loader?
Like, does the loader need to know about the state?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
What do you mean by declaration?
Like, what are you putting inside?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Like, for example, if I put the use query inside the
You mean to create your own version of the query?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Oh, sorry, of the loader?
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_9
Yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
No, it's a bit more complicated than that.
You need to create some custom defined, a query loader, for example,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
a Tansy query loader that will at some point call use query
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_3
instead of its code.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Oh, OK.
So I see.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it's not as easy as just putting the loader into the query
NOTE Speaker: posva
into the loader.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The reason it requires some, it's definitely not easy.
Also, because some of the features that I have on the loaders
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
are a bit complex.
So if you look at the implementation for the basic loader,
NOTE Speaker: posva
it's a bit shorter.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The loader is a bit longer because of the extra features it had.
And they can serve as a starting point as well.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
The reason is I tend to move a lot of the complexity
from the user code to the library code as much as possible.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I really believe that a good API should be very easy in 80%.
It's difficult to explain without the words,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
but I have another talk where they explain this,
what is a good design, a good API design.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So for 80% of the use cases, it should be very easy.
And then it should get exponentially harder
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
to get things done.
So you're sacrificing the real hard work
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
and the real uncommon use cases for a more complex code,
but making extremely easy to get what most people need to do.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you have a kind of curve.
What was the curve?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
If you have the complexity.
Yeah, how common it is.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So on the original act, it goes like, is this very common?
And then the vertical acts will be the difficulty.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so it should be something like it goes very low,
NOTE Speaker: posva
and then it goes up really quick.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's like it's, OK.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So it should be.
OK.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's like an inverted logarithmic curve.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I haven't done a lot of math of this kind for a long time,
NOTE Speaker: posva
so I don't want to say anything.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
There is some exponential in there.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you optimize for the most common use cases
and sacrifice the very complex use cases.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I mean, you don't sacrifice them.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You just make it a bit harder to implement them.
NOTE Speaker: Speaker_2
Yeah, it's hard.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Sacrifice the API, I would say.
So the API is not adapted for those cases.
NOTE Speaker: posva
This is very abstract.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But the idea is only very, very extremely personalized use
NOTE Speaker: posva
cases.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It should be a little bit hard.
It should be harder to do, but not impossible.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Not impossible at all.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It's just that you roll back to the lower level of the API,
NOTE Speaker: posva
so you have to implement some other things yourself.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so it requires way more work than having a linear API, which
NOTE Speaker: posva
I think is really bad API design.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you said earlier that the Vue community strives to always
have one solution for one problem.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Is there a similar effort with data loaders?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yes.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
OK, so what I mean is, what I said is more,
we have official solutions for the,
NOTE Speaker: posva
so we have official solutions.
That's the short version.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It means that anything that is really needed in applications,
like the core foundation of, the core foundation should be,
NOTE Speaker: posva
we have official solutions.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So that's the router and state management alongside Vue.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And then we have things like ESLint.
And there are other things that right now,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I don't have any other testing abstraction as well.
So we try as much as we can to have official solutions
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
for the things that are important, DevTools as well.
And then other specific solutions are created by the community,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
right, contributed by the community.
Next, in the end, is still a community project in a way.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Internationalization, it's also a community project, and so on.
So data loaders, similar to Pinia,
NOTE Speaker: posva
I like to start projects on the side.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
That way I can iterate a bit faster on the ideas that are not leveled as,
NOTE Speaker: posva
as official.
And once they get leveled as official,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
you get a lot more of users that have different, more different,
a more, a different demographic, right?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you have people who have different levels of knowledge,
and it takes a lot more effort to adapt the documentation,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
some of the warnings, some of the APIs as well,
to match the same level of quality that we have in Vue, I would say.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it's easier to iterate faster during this period with less documentation,
NOTE Speaker: posva
simplified API.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So you only have users who are actually quite good.
They are, they are more experienced developers, more seasoned developers.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And so they're able to give you interesting feedback,
which is not the case for some of the beginners developers.
NOTE Speaker: posva
But then once you get official,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
you need to be able to be easy for beginners as well.
And this is way harder than it looks like.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So actually, the reason I'm asking is on the Vue Unplugged in Router repository,
I looked through the issues and there are quite a few issues from like Vue,
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Nuxt maintainers.
And I wondered, is there maybe a future where Nuxt uses the next generation Vue router under the hood?
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So it already uses, this is why there are some issues with that.
It already uses, but only for the types.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Okay.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So in the future, I mean, I talked to Daniel and Sebastian and I'm close to the team anyway.
So I try to ensure that there is nothing breaking for them.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
In the future, it will be better if it could be completely integrated.
So for that, I only need to make sure that every piece of API is open enough for Nuxt to work with it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Right now, they don't use the parsing of the file system.
So some of the APIs I expose them only for them.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So they can actually generate the types based on a structure.
And they can build a structure themselves.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I think something like that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So for example, you have an experimental type pages like on Nuxt config that you can set to true.
You have type routes, but you don't have the data.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
You have data loaders and all the features.
So I need to build, which is one of the things that I do right now is build the modules to make that easy.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But there's still, because they don't use the Vite plugin, there is no parsing on the code.
And some of the things happen at build time to make just your life a little bit easier.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Like you can even remove the export of the data loaders and stuff like that.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And it will still work.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So these are still not working on Nuxt unfortunately.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Actually, a little fun side fact.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
My team uses a Vue Unplugin router.
And I use Vue Unplugin router internally.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And I needed to convince my boss before.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Because we were building this SBA and it has been around for a long time.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And it's built on Vue router.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I wanted to like introduce loaders.
And I didn't want to like write my own, roll my own version on top of before entry route hooks.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I looked into your library and I was like, oh, this is beautiful.
But it had this like small little experimental label on it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
So I showed it to my boss and he was like, experimental.
That might be a hard, a hard thing.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
It might change after, after.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I looked who is using it.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I found it inside the Nuxt dependencies.
So I was like, I went to my boss and I was like, look, Nuxt is depending on it.
NOTE Speaker: posva
There's not going to be so much breaking change.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
But yeah, of course, we knew it was a high risk adventure.
But it was better than the opportunity, which was like hand rolling our own stack.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
No one knows Vue router better than you.
So who else to implement it?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Thanks.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And most of the API, yeah, it's, it's been good.
It's been pretty much stable.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Like most of the changes are, are small.
The whole structure, like if you use file based routing, the whole file based routing has been pretty much stable from the beginning because it was supposed to be mapped to what Nuxt could do.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
I didn't want to buy shed too much on the syntax.
So there are a few things that do not exist in Nuxt.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Well, I mean, just one mainly named named views.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I had to introduce a syntax for that.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And I will probably introduce syntax.
Similar to SvelteKit or Nuxt, I think, where you have a page or route with a plus in the front or a dollar or whatever.
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
And these allows you to define sometimes information that are relative to the route.
NOTE Speaker: posva
But you don't have a page.
So you can have nesting of information like meta properties and stuff like that.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And there are a few things that can change, but minor breaking changes.
Most of the APIs, if they are exposed, they are unlikely to change too much.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And everything.
So things that are actually experimental, they are marked experimental again inside of the package.
NOTE Speaker: posva
This is experimental, could change because I'm still having confirm.
I think it's mostly the editable tree, editable route tree or something like that, which is it's a bit too much.
NOTE Speaker: posva
You have to it's supposed to allow users to map to a route array.
So you're able to edit the tree in a way that is similar to how you edited routes array, which is something people used to do a lot.
NOTE Speaker: posva
But.
Because it's done at build time, it gives the type safety.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And so this part of being edited at build time also includes also add sorry limitations like you cannot add a random code into the functions.
For example, anything that is not so realizable cannot be added to the tree.
NOTE Speaker: posva
They have these limitations that you have to overcome in runtime.
But people already already did that.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So they should be able to copy paste that code anyway.
Very interesting.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And for data loaders, I believe they are like one of the more stable.
Parts of the experimental view, which are sweet.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Do you have like an estimate for when they might make it to the official viewer to the official view router?
I don't know.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's true that in the future I would imagine integrating the unplugging view router or maybe just a VEET plugin.
I know I'm not sure yet of how to integrate everything because I have issues that I can only fix issues with HHMR.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So hot module replacement that can only be fixed for VEET.
And I just don't have the capacity to write the code for how many bundlers do we have like six?
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's just too much.
So Webpack and VEET usually they work pretty much the same.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And as long as people have the same API as VEET, it should be fine.
My goal is probably to include this in view router package at some point.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Not in the package in the repository.
It will still be a separate package that you install, I think, because it's important to keep the separation for major version is just easier.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It's not far from having a stable version.
I think I have a few.
NOTE Speaker: posva
This is just more personal.
I take a lot of time to mark a version as stable way more than other people.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And it's more that with personal life.
I have delayed this a lot, but it's not far from having a stable release that I have like few small changes.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I want to add to loaders improvements, which should not even be breaking changes.
But just in case I have to wait, I have the naming the default naming because you can configure the naming of the routes anyway.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I wanted to change the default naming maybe to be easy to differentiate from a string path.
So I still need to think a little bit about it.
NOTE Speaker: posva
See what other people are doing.
See if somebody has a better idea.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And maybe sometimes it helps you see things from a different perspective.
And apart from that, I think it's all features and it hasn't had any.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It hasn't had many breaking changes.
I mean, I still had nine breaking changes, right?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Technically, because I had version 10.
I mean, 0.10.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I do breaking changes.
Since I'm still on 0. something, the breaking changes happens on the minor.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So any minor version is a breaking change, at least sometimes small ones.
To give a comment from a user perspective, the breaking changes have not been very big.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It was very easy to adjust to them.
I'm glad.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I don't even remember anymore what were.
The dialogs did have a breaking change.
NOTE Speaker: posva
They were quite big, but it was necessary because I discovered a big flaw.
I'm trying to check.
NOTE Speaker: posva
What did I have?
I have a breaking change.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It requires your router for 0.4.
Okay.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Create router now requires the explicit router.
So it was for TypeScript.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah, it was like I discovered flows and I was like, okay, I need to fix this.
And then eight was a lot of data loaders.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah, it was changing types.
Honestly, the whole type was I felt like it was so fragile at the beginning and also did
NOTE Speaker: posva
relying on the virtual files on V has been a little bit of a roller coaster sometimes
through no longer relative to routes folder.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So this was more like a fix.
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I mean, it's not that our fixes technically, but it's like, oh, I could break people.
So let's just, oh, actually, no, there are another many breaking changes because before
NOTE Speaker: posva
I was just doing it for features sometimes.
There are a few like rename five pattern to five patterns because it's, I was an array.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
These are small, small changes, but hopefully, yeah, it hasn't had big change, big, big breaking
NOTE Speaker: posva
change for a while.
I think it's June.
NOTE Speaker: posva
No, may, may was the last one.
The big last one.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So I think like, this is probably all the time we've got for today.
Mr.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I guess I can always look myself as if your company uses, uses the sponge, the open source.
I do consider reaching out or for sponsorships.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I'm still looking to find a balance between the open source and freelancing.
And I have very nice options for companies to have a direct connection.
NOTE Speaker: posva
I can direct being able to just talk to me about the issue, the issues they have.
So they can, the developers are usually really happy with these because they can ask very
NOTE Speaker: posva
technical questions or again,
I can help them debug bugs and it saves them hours.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So it's really just worth the money, which is just sponsoring.
You also have courses, right?
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
I have a mastering Pina course, which is named after Pina, but in reality is very, it's about
NOTE Speaker: posva
stores.
So it helps you out.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It helps you learn a lot about view itself, the composition API.
And yeah, it's very recent.
NOTE Speaker: posva
It has only one year old.
So it's still very, very, very, uh, what's the term not up to date, but relevant.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Yeah.
It's relevant.
NOTE Speaker: posva
No, it's relevant for the currency.
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: posva
So it's been very, very good.
Like people are like, yeah, I learned so much.
NOTE Speaker: posva
None of these, I never thought about these, never saw these API anywhere else.
NOTE Speaker: And now I can use it for some, some of my features and it simplifies my code so much.@posva
Yeah.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Really happy about it.
It's also really fun.
NOTE Speaker: posva
A lot of exercises.
Fantastic.
NOTE Speaker: posva
And where can people go to follow you?
Uh, on Twitter on so X or GitHub as posva.
NOTE Speaker: posva
That's where I hang out most of the time.
Okay.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Thank you so much for coming on today.
It was a pleasure.
NOTE Speaker: posva
Thank you.
Bye.
NOTE Speaker: posva
.